in a recent conversation with Vanity
Fair Avengers infinity war screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
revealed that smart Hulk almost made his
dramatic debut in the third act of that
film during the battle of Wakanda the
wide-ranging interview pulled back the
curtain on the massively complicated
process through which the two writers
hammered out the plot for infinity war
an endgame banners transformation into
Professor Hulk was originally set to
take place during infinity war at a time
in the scripting process when the film's
final act was completely different from
the one we eventually ended up seeing in
this early version each of the Avengers
faced a gut-check before the final
battle in Wakanda a gut-check of a very
strange nature Markus explained there
was a sequence in infinity war where the
Avengers went into the places in the
Doctor Strange universe called the
mindscape and everyone phases themselves
it was great but had absolutely nothing
to do with anything
McFeely continued to say that if this
had been kept Hulk's entrance into the
battle of Wakanda would have been pretty
memorable The Hulk refuses to come out
if you remember and in the early
storyline they eventually came to a
realization or a compromise and he
busted out of the Iron Man suit and
beats the heck out of this monster
breaking down the reason for the change
though McFeely pointed out that one too
many victorious moments during that
fateful melee would have diluted the
Avengers infinity wars marched toward
Thanos's ultimate victory in doing so he
also revealed that the two movies weird
shooting schedule meant that a key end
game scene had to be reshot
once it was determined that Professor
Hulk wouldn't pop up an infinity war
that whole third act is a march toward
losing and this hulk scene is a big win
right it's a guy solving his problem and
being a funny character because now he's
eloquent we had to at the last second
scrap all that put aside all these
scenes that used to have smart Hulk and
then reshoot the first act of endgame
that used to have the smart Hulk Markus
elaborated that another reason for
pushing smart Hulk's debut until the
first act of endgame helped illustrate
the changes everyone had gone through
after the five-year time jump we wanted
everybody to have this enormous journey
in the
your jump and to really see in sometimes
shocking ways how the loss had affected
them we hadn't given banner a change
because we had transformed him earlier
and he had nowhere to go suddenly by
needing to take it out of the first
movie it was the perfect thing I put the
brains and the Brawn together and now
they give me best of both worlds this
helps to explain a significant mystery
why Hulk in all his green glory was
shown at the Battle of Wakanda in the
trailers for infinity war Markus and
McFeely confirmed that portions of the
climactic battle were shot in which
Banner went into battle as the Hulk but
those scenes also had to be removed and
then reshot the massive Vanity Fair
interview helps to illustrate why
everyone is still interested in parsing
out the final parts of how infinity war
and end game were made so long after the
fact there are probably no two
blockbusters in existence with more
moving parts and it's easy to see how
things could have gone disastrously
wrong at virtually any stage
fortunately for fans of superhero cinema
all over the world Markus McFeely and co
directors Joe and Anthony Russo somehow
managed to make all of those moving
parts sync up as close to perfectly as
seems possible it all resulted in two of
the finest comic-book movies ever made
and in the case of endgame the single
biggest film of all time still we would
have absolutely freaked out to see Hulk
literally busting the Hulkbuster suit
unfortunately when you're in the
business of making ultra blockbusters
even some perfect moments have to go to
make the final product work check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU moments are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]